we're now going to take a look at some
of magnus carson's
five best moments from chess.com's
previous
online competitions in preparation for
the big one you're going to be watching
aren't you make sure you're watching
only a couple of weeks the 2020
chess.com speed chess championships
remember to like and subscribe to this
channel
and we'll move over to example number
one for beginner oh look at that hikaru
nakamura right as i said it
he trapped his own queen robert you
missed it he trapped his own queen
i mean that's just you know that's going
to be absolutely
heartbreaking for hikaru absolutely in
this first example
hikaru has the white pieces and he gets
himself in a little bit
of a discombobulated muddle puddle
disaster zone now magnus
traps his queen in very nice style maybe
not the most amazing
tactics but i'm sure again magnus would
have enjoyed
hikaru now should have brought his queen
back somewhere
well d3 the only square instead he goes
to where four
how does that queen now find itself
stranded
in really the middle of the board
g5 this move traps the queen and hikaru
resigned immediately it's very peculiar
to get a queen trapped
like that but if the queen tries to run
away to f3
bishop g4 meets make sure it has no
other escape
route so a nice little simple victory
for carlson we're starting easy they're
going to get a little more
difficult and let's move on to the next
one now
yeah i'll be doing it and i guess his
idea is after king f2 bishop c4
he's actually threatening mate with
queen takes e3 king of uh
yeah queen takes e3 and uh
no this is this is just over this is
just like a wipeout in round
in round one one thing that makes these
top players stand out is their tactical
ability
and their vision their ability to see
tactics
instantaneously bang like a lightning
bolt
us mere mortals just cannot keep up with
them
in this game wesley so has just played
f4 but this allows
a winning combination can you see the
combination which comprises
of many small parts first of all
magnus plays bishop d4 you should always
look
for the most challenging move a move
that's gonna put your opponent
on the back foot this is attacking the e
pawn
that pawn cannot capture the bishop
because the rook is on pretty
maybe wesley thought he was okay after
rook to e1 but now comes the second
stage bishop takes e free
check rook takes e3 and now
one more capture on e3 and here comes
the next stage of the tactic queen
d4 and really when playing this whole
idea with bishop d4 you needed
to be able to see up to this moment and
even one will move
deeper this rook is in what we can call
an eternal pin
it can't move because the king will be
in check and if black is simply allowed
to play rook takes e3 it's curtains time
so king f2 is the only option but now
bishop takes c4 the final move the queen
is attacked on b3 and wherever the queen
moves to
queen takes e3 will win the game and
again it's just this vision that we all
need to improve our own chess but these
guys
they are just so quick so fast hence
making the champions that they are and
you're right back in that critical
moment we saw that magnus
you know his sixth sense or whatever he
played this move d7 everybody right when
grisham didn't have much time you can
see on the analysis board and that's
what got
sasha f6 and the f7 check is coming
right
yeah rookie back king d8 f7 game one and
uh and already magnus does what he does
best
he just swindled his way to a victory
based
mainly on the fact that grisha didn't
have enough time
to solve the issues to solve the
landmine of tricks that magnus laid out
spotting tactics at any moment in the
game whether it be the opening
middle game and ending is key it's all
good and fair getting a good position in
the ending but if you missed the win
you might miss your opportunity here we
see magnus with the white pieces
playing against grizzchuk the chess
gangster the og of the chessboard
how did now magnus use a little series
of moves to
force the win of a piece or queening of
the pawn the first move is pretty
obvious but can you see the next
steps well he first plays
f6 threatening just to slam that pawn
all the way into f8 there's only one way
to stop it and you've got to consider
your opponent's best defensive move so
hopefully you saw bishop to g6 and now
the key move
f7 check this is the move
you needed to see there's only one way
to stop that queening and here
white can play rook 2e7 check the final
piece of the puzzle the king cannot hold
on to the bishop
well if it does it will be going into
the line of white's bishop
and rook to e2 discovered check will win
that rook on c2 magnus being a rook up
and if king to d8 has played in the game
just rook takes off seven magnus has won
a piece
he's pretty good in the ending anyway
you don't really want to give him peace
odds
as well as that not a wise idea and he
went on to clear up
in quite quick time here in this next
example we're gonna see magnus carson's
attacking ability in full motion
his opponent is tigran petrosian
petrosian
of the new age not the old age and
in this position magnus has the two
bishops but
what move forces its way through
and the breakthrough into black's actual
structure
the move is rook takes g6
a lovely move here this opens up the
black king
if the king takes the rook bishop f5 is
checkmate
and if the queen takes the rook bishop
f5
simply wins the queen and after rook
takes g6 tigran
resigned because there's no good way to
stop the rook coming in
to g7 a nice sweet and simple tactic
there
in this next one tigran petrossian is
again on the receiving end of some
punishments not for the first time
in his life but it's this attack which
comes from nowhere
which makes this very special we have
what looks like kind of a
long ending but what move did magnus now
play
spotting an opportunity which many other
players would not
have seen knight takes
g5 does this lose a piece no
it draws the black king into a really
bad position
for example now black played knight to
get to f8 but clearly here
black's just lost the pawn you don't
want to do that against magnus the point
though
is if king takes g5 rook takes e6
places the black king into a checkmate
position
f4 the very pretty and deadly fret
and the only way to stop this would be
knight f6 but after f4
and something like g5 to continue the
piece has won back with an easily
winning game
magnus there demonstrating some
beautiful tactical vision
in i suppose what you could say some
nice crisp and simple
tactics will he become 2020s
chess.com speedchest champion make sure
you keep your eyes open make sure you
don't miss
any of the games there it's gonna be
brilliant to see
i'm not sure who can beat magnus but if
there is one person
you'd have to bet on hikaru well let's
well we're gonna have to wait and see
what you guys reckon
do like and subscribe to this video and
hopefully i'll be back again soon with
more